welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's track on systems
pharmacology in designing precision
therapeutics it's my pleasure to
introduce you dr. Adam Palmer a systems
biologist and a postdoctoral fellow with
Peter Sauber in the laboratory of
systems pharmacology at Harvard Medical
School dr. Palmer is working on the
analysis and design of combination
cancer therapies he applies experiments
theory and analysis of data from
clinical trials of cancer therapies with
a particular interest in the origins and
therapeutic consequences of cell to cell
and patients patient heterogeneity in
cancers for a complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr. Palmer's
keynote presentation is titled the
impact of patient patient and
variability on combination cancer
therapy and precision oncology my name
is Judy O'Rourke and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laggards
laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now that further ado please join
me in welcoming dr. Adam Palmer I will
now turn the presentation over to him
thank you for introduction Judy so I'm
going to talk today about my research on
patient the patient variability and
company
in cancer therapy and discuss the
implications of this work for precision
medicine in oncology so most cancers are
treated with combinations of multiple
cancer therapies because they are
observed in clinical trials to improve
patients chances of survival so it's
illustrated in this picture here for
example if we have a cancer cell which
has been treated with two or sometimes
more therapies acting on different
targets and what is in many cases
observed but not for all combinations
but for some combinations that the use
of those multiple therapies can improve
patients odds of survival and there's a
multitude of reasons why different
combinations of drugs can have this
beneficial effect on patient survival
the first issue to consider is that the
drugs might act upon pathways that have
some functional interaction or the
activity of one drug upon the cell might
changed the way the cell responds to a
second row but ideally that could
enhance its activity and give rise to a
synergistic killing of the cancer cell a
different issue to consider is that
within any cancer is a collection of
genetically and phenotypically
heterogeneous cells and those cells
might vary in their degree of
sensitivity to each of two drugs and
finally when it comes to a human
clinical trial one will observe a still
greater degree of heterogeneity among
different patients tumors in their
degree of responsiveness to each of the
different drugs within a combination and
this is most clearly observed in
clinical trial results themselves where
for example if you look at these
survival distribution colored in red
there are patients treated with just one
therapy you'll see there is some
percentage of patients out on the far
right-hand side of the survival curve
where that treatment has been very
effective for them and there will be
other patients with not only the same
type of cancer receiving the same
therapy so the treatment is not very
effective and rapidly fails so from this
view then we can understand three
general rationales for combining cancer
therapies the first thing that the
trophy could give rise to an additive or
synergistic effect that could be
more effective at killing every
individual cell within a cancer secondly
combinations of multiple drugs could be
effective at overcoming the clonal
heterogeneity that exists within a
cancer and this mechanism could be as
simple as that some fraction of the
cells are resistant to drug a and they
can instead be killed by a different
drug B that acts by a different
mechanism of action and finally the same
logic can also play out at the scale of
patient to patient variability that in a
collection of patients treated with
therapies
some of them might respond well the drug
a some of them might be resistant to
drug a and among those who don't benefit
from drug a some of them might instead
benefit from a different drug be the
historical rationale for using
combinations of cancer therapies if you
go back and read papers from the 1940s
and 1950s about why we should use
combinations of drugs it was very much
inspired by the success of combination
therapy at eradicating tuberculosis and
the concept that was overcoming clonal
heterogeneity in defeating the evolution
of drug resistance so the scenario at
the centre here today with a molecular
understanding of cancer there is a more
dominant emphasis on understanding
interactions among drugs and cases where
we could achieve synergistic killing of
cancer cells with combination therapies
and what I've going to talk mostly about
today is the scenario on the right hand
side the role of patient the patient
variability in responsiveness to
different cancer therapies and the
significance of this phenomenon became
apparent in some of the earliest human
clinical trials of combination therapies
for cancer answer so this data comes
from 1961 when the acute leukemia group
B was testing different combinations of
anti Kimia therapies in children with
acute lymphocytic leukemia and what they
observed in one of these trials was that
they could achieve about a 25% rate of
remission among patients treated with
macaco Pury they could also achieve
about a 25% rate of remission of 93
patients treated with methotrexate and
if they treated those patients with both
drugs at the same time there was a
actually higher rate for permission so
one possible interpretation this is that
the two drugs are more effectively
killing the cancer cells in individuals
and there's some fraction of patients
who do not benefit from either single
agent but who do benefit from the both
mixed together
however this trial was paid crossover
the trial where there was three
different arms investigated first
patients could receive methotrexate and
when that eventually failed they could
swap over to Mikado curing or they could
be treated with McArthur purine and then
swap to methotrexate or received both at
the same time and what they observed in
this crossover was that among the
patients who said he did not respond to
the captain purine if they were treated
with methotrexate that's exceeded about
25 percent of the time they did benefit
from the captor purine and had a
remission well when that remission
eventually gave way to relapse if they
were then treated with methotrexate
again it's exceeded about 25 percent of
the time so it was clear that the
activity of the different drugs were not
overlapping on the same individuals and
that gave rise to this understanding of
population structure illustrated in this
grid here where you have among the group
of patients laid out in that Square
there's some chance of response to
mcafee of hearing and some separate
chance of response to methotrexate and
those chances do overlap as much as you
would expect by random chance
but then the benefit of the combination
therapy can be calculated simply the
response rate or R in this equation here
the response rate the drug a plus B is
the response rates of drug a plus the
fraction of patients who don't benefit
from that might respond to the second
drug just based on the degree of
activity that displays all by itself and
what they found over a series of trials
of different drug combinations was that
every way they had of combining the
Kapton purine methotrexate
prednisone and vincristine always the
remission rates for the drug
combinations were fairly predictable
based upon the activities of the single
agent what they concluded from now is
that the data suggests that the
advantage derives from the two drugs
acting independently on the patient
so coming back to this illustration of
different rationales for combination
therapy it's very interesting about this
phenomenon of between tumor
heterogeneity is that it makes a
quantitative prediction of how much
activity the combination therapy should
exhibit based upon the single drug
activities now this is a baseline level
of benefit that occurs before there is
any stronger benefit of the matter of
overcoming heterogeneity within
individual patients tumors or having
synergistic effects on individual cancer
cells so we can see what's being
predicted here is what's the band
vanillin benefit that is obtained simply
because you have two differently active
drugs so that phenomenon was understood
at some level as of 1965 and for reasons
that I can only speculate about it was
largely overlooked in the remaining 50
years and so I'll present now my
analysis of how this phenomenon applies
to contemporary clinical trials data so
the first thing to present here is the
nature of clinical trials data today
it's no longer evaluated on something as
simple as response rate but rather
distributions of survival times so this
is an example of a survival function
where the vertical axis shows the
percentage of patients whose tumors are
under control or a phenomenon known as
progression free survival and as time
goes by on treatment more and more
patients have their tumor developed
resistance to the therapy and start to
continue growing in every time that
patients tumor grows that curve goes
down some amount so the underlying data
behind these clinical trials is rarely
you've never published and so what was
necessary to perform an analysis of this
data first was to use image processing
algorithms that digitally trace these
curves and extract the data and so when
I developed was a pipeline where one
could go from a published clinical trial
figure for example the New England
Journal of Medicine and apply image
processing to extract digitized survival
distributions and there are hyperlinks
at the bottom of the slide here where
you can download the soft
I used performance and consists of
mathematical scripts the first example
of a trial that will analyze here is
combination immunotherapy for the
treatment of metastatic melanoma now
this particular plot here is a curve of
a distributions of patients tumor volume
changes so this could be understood as a
series of bar charts in fact but which
have been collapsed to a single line so
you could imagine a series of columns
that are every individual patient and
you are showing these sets of data for
different treatment regimes where the
lower the curve is the better that's
more patients have more tumor shrinkage
and we see in pink the responses to the
immunotherapy appeal a new map and that
produces tumor shrinkage in about 1/3 of
the patients and in green is responses
to the follow map which produces
chambers shrinkage in a little over 50%
of patients and in blue is the observed
activity of the combination of both
therapies which is achieved tumor
shrinkage in a higher fraction of
patients than any single drug so the
simulation of what these drugs should
have do in combination under this model
of purely independent activity consists
of for each patient randomly sampling a
response from the appealin and that
distribution then randomly sampling a
response from the devala map
distribution and choosing the better one
of the two single drugs and this is then
repeated to simulate distribution of
responses across patients and that
produces the line shown in black and
what you can observe here is that the
superior activity of the combination
therapy is very close to what is
predicted under this model of drug
independence we can perform the same
analysis on the progression-free
survival data showing how long patients
tumors are under control and I'll
explain here a different simpler way to
perform the analysis if you are working
with progression-free survival
distributions so what we can apply here
is to take the equation that I presented
earlier and the
that equation fell the application of
yes progression-free survival so the
expected the survival distribution for a
combination of drugs a and B is well
it's at least as good as the survival
distribution for trigati alone plus the
fraction of patients who do not respond
to drug a might respond to drug B and
this particular calculation in fact
slightly overestimates the observed
activity of the combination therapy and
so what was missing here was an
accounting for cross resistance between
the drugs which can be captured in this
equation with a correlation parameter
Rho so what's being described here by
this correlation or cross resistance is
that the patients who are resistant to
drug a might have a worse than average
chance of being resisted to try B and in
this particular clinical trial we see in
this curve in black here that the best
fit to this clinical data is obtained by
assuming a partial positive degree of
correlations or a partial degree of
cross resistance and that's consistent
with what's clinically observed in
crossover trials of these theories but
if for example you take a patient who
has failed to respond to the pill in the
net and treat them are foods with
Navarro map it has a slightly lower rate
of response but certainly not a zero
rate of response so everyone when the
actively if this combination therapy
it's a superior treatment in terms of
efficacy it improves patients odds of
survival and that benefit can be
explained by patients each receiving
their best single agent response so that
it doesn't appear that the drugs are
adding up to a stronger effect in
individuals but rather they have a
benefit at the population level because
of differences among individuals in who
responds best to appeal in the lab or
who responds best in the follow map so
what this illustrates is that for one
parameter here the one free parameter is
the cross resistance between the drugs
if Fraga is working or not working for
you what does that mean about the chance
of activity from drug B and ideally what
we would like to know is for the same
patient how would they respond if they
receive drug B and how would they
instead respond had they received drug a
and
not possible to gain that insight from a
human clinical trial where different
patients are assaulted to receiving
different treatments but it is possible
to obtain this insight using patient
derived humor Xena graphs this is a
setting where you can take a single
patient's tumor and implant it into
multiple mice that it then received
different treatments and you can see for
example it's some fraction of the tumors
that are treated with drug or drug be
respond to therapy as illustrated in red
here you can ask is it the same tumors
that are responding to the different
treatments or is it different sets of
treatments that are responding to the
different treatments the the largest set
of data at this time that I was able to
analyze came from Novartis who has
developed a library of patient-derived
key Mazzini grafts and in this article
by tweaked-out published in 2015 in
Nature Medicine they release full
underlying data for 230 of slightly more
than that xenograph models across six
different types of cancers treated with
a variety of different single agents and
combinations of therapies so I mind all
of this data to look at the correlations
between different drugs and what is
observed in this data is the general
trend is one of a partial positive
correlation so resistance to drag a
tends to be bad news for the chance of
response to drug B but there is a lot of
heterogeneity in there the correlations
are higher if you look at drugs acting
on the same pathway and they can be a
little bit lower than average if you're
looking at drugs with clearly different
mechanisms of action for example
comparing a cytotoxic chemotherapy or a
targeted inhibitor of allergenic
signaling the therapeutic implication of
this low correlation or differences
among who responds best to which drug is
nicely illustrated by this data which
comes from gastric cancer Cigna grafts
treated with a pi3 kinase inhibitor
illustrated in green or an antibody drug
conjugate against FGFR illustrated in
purple you see that the been drug on
average is the kinase inhibitor and the
antibody therapy
is for about 80% of the tumors is no
better than untreated and only in a
subset is it highly active you might
look on this survival curve that in that
20% subset responding that there is a
similar degree of response to the kinase
inhibitor or the antibody therapy this
is in a sense an optical illusion of
survival curves that those longest
responses are in the bottom part of the
curve but they're not necessarily in the
same individuals now if this were a
human clinical trial you wouldn't be
able to know it but because it's Xena
graphs we could instead plot this as bar
charts and look side-by-side for each
individual tumor how does that single
chamber respond to each of the two
different therapies and what we see here
is that the antibody in purple is
producing some very strong responses in
a number of tumors that are not
responding particularly well to the
kinase inhibitor and green so if these
therapies were combined and each
individual's cheerless response to the
two of them was just the best single
agent response you would still expect to
see a significant improvement in the
survival function illustrated here in
black so what this data show is is that
simply because different tumors can
respond best to different therapies
combinations of therapies can improve
response rates even without any activity
between the drugs a different insight
that can be obtained from ping through
this large cohort xenograft data is to
see the more broadly the way in which
drug combinations are beneficial by
overcoming our inability to predict the
best personalized treatment so we can
ask given this data for every xenograph
what is its average response to a single
drug and what is its average response to
one of the combinations of drugs that it
was treated with and you see in these
survival functions in green and blue
that on average combination therapies
are superior to mono therapies but if we
go through this data and fruit xenograph
choose random pairs of mono therapies
and select the best single one of those
two responses there are responses to be
- these random pairs of mono therapies
is almost as good as what is observed
for the average responses to
combinations now this certainly does not
mean that we should treat cancers with
random pairs of drugs because certainly
the average response to therapies is not
as good as the best response to a
particular therapy for a particular
tumor type we can use this data to apply
in a retrospective sense the extreme
form of personalized therapy that we can
look amongst the twenty or so different
therapies that each tumor received what
was the single best response it had to
any single drug and what was the one
best response that chima had to any
particular combination therapy and if we
go across all 230 s in the graph and
plot the Cir variable distribution for
their responses to the absolute best
single drug or the absolute best
combination therapy but first you can
certainly see this is much better than
their average responses to therapies but
comparing the best retrospective mono
therapy or the best retrospective
combination they look very similar to
one another so this shows that broadly
across this data if you knew how to
choose the best single drug for each
individual there would not be such a
strong need for combination therapies in
these cases the benefit of combination
therapies on average stems from the fact
that in practice it is very difficult to
know one is going to be best for an
individual it's also worth noting these
were all models of metastatic solid
tumors and the scenario among the
benefits of combination therapies can be
quite different in the patinas and
lymphomas that I'll briefly note at the
end so the theta4 xenograph
is very interesting but ultimately what
matters is how this film plays out in
human clinical trial data so this slide
now shows the application of this
analysis to a variety of human clinical
trials of combination therapies across a
variety of advanced solid cancers and
what we're doing here is taking
responses to different individual
treatments in green and purple and
applying this equation to calculate the
that effect of the combination therapy
under this model of Independence are
more specific really a model of the best
single agent response in every
individual patient and now we can
compare this prediction in black to the
observed effect in the clinical trial
data of the combination therapy shown in
blue and we see then on the bottom in
the cases marked by red stars are some
cases where the observed activity of the
combination therapy in blue is
substantially superior to the predicted
effect of the combination so here there
are cases where the two drugs are
genuinely achieving a stronger response
in individual patients for example on
the bottom left and bottom centering
ovarian and colorectal cancers these are
both trailers combining the angiogenesis
inhibitor Venice's amad with a cocktail
of other cytotoxic chemotherapy so and
what we understand in these cases is
that the application of it angiogenesis
inhibitor normalizes the tumor
vasculature improves the delivery of
chemotherapy to the tumor conversely in
the cases in the top two rows we can see
that the activity of the combination
therapy does not seem to be exhibiting
any degree of synergistic activity
inside human patients treated with these
therapies that doesn't rule out that
there are mechanisms of interactions
between the drugs there could be all
sorts of molecular interactions between
the drugs effects but they don't have a
substantial benefit in terms of the
duration of tumor control one case worth
noting is it b-raf muted metastatic
melanoma treated but the briefly been
fermented in that case one of the major
clinical benefits of combining those is
that tremendum diminishes some of the
skin toxicity caused by a BRAF lip but
in terms of the efficacy of chamber
control it does not surpass the
prediction of independent action now no
part of this analysis changes the
original conclusions of the clinical
trials that these are combination
therapies that significantly improve
patient's odds of survival but it
changes our understanding Mehcad
of why it is that they're not beneficial
they do not necessarily need to have
synergistic interactions between drugs
but rather it can be beneficial to
combine drugs simply in the case where
some set of patients will benefit well
from drug and some set of patients will
benefit both from trophy but if we don't
know who should get which one then the
patient's odds of a strong response has
improved if they receive both this is
very much to call for further
improvement of precision methods more
very broadly across oncology there are
some important limitations to note in
this analysis first it's very important
in these calculations that were only
comparing trials with the dosages of the
drugs or the the dosing regimens were
identical or very similar between the
mono therapy and the combination therapy
anse and that has been the case for the
clinical trials that I presented here
that if they would dose differences they
were there in mine or temporary changes
in dosage more broadly across oncology
there are lots of trials where there are
substantial changes in postage in the
combination therapy home and that would
make it difficult to apply this analysis
it doesn't mean that the phenomenon that
patient the patient variability plays a
role in the benefit of the combination
therapy
I believe the phenomenon could apply
very broadly but it becomes difficult in
these cases to calculate what sort of
benefit of that phenomenon you would
expect if we do not know how a dose
change alters the efficacy of one
particular ingredient in a combination
therapy the second limitation is that
the correlation drug response or the
cross resistance between drugs is a very
important parameter and there's not a
whole lot of data on that so for the
purpose of the data that I presented
here we made use of the response
correlations as they were observed in
the patient arrived chamber xenografts
it generally varied between point 1 and
point 5 sometimes this data can be
obtained from clinical trials for in
particular crossover trials where
patients receive treatment a and then
switch to receiving treatment B after it
fails and so for example in this data
illustrated here looking at home track
presumptive responses inline canisters
we can see here that there is no
correlation between the activity of this
chemotherapy or targeted therapy but
this sort of data is hard to come by
another limitation is that if there are
mmm if the responses to multiple drugs
really are going to add up to something
stronger it's likely to be in that set
of patients when both drugs are active
both delivering some substantial degree
of chima cell killing and you might seem
much more killing when they're both
present so the serval illustrated in
purple about little grid of patients on
the bottom right and often in human
clinical trial data the follow-up might
not be long enough to track those
survival curves all the way down to zero
and so it might be in some cases that
the fraction of patients who really
respond best to each of those two drugs
they may or may not be an additive most
synergistic effect there and the
clinical trial data sometimes is simply
not able to give an answer to that
question finally there were some cases
where it is possible to find a clinical
trial that tested treatment alo
treatment B line and treatment a
combined with B that's the ideal sort of
day didn't work with often though it is
the case that a clinical trial would
test treatment a plus or minus treatment
B without having data on treatment B by
itself and in those cases it may be
necessary to make the best available
insight will come from a cross trial
comparison and if that's going to happen
it's absolutely vital to make sure that
the patient enrollment criteria are
really very closely aligned in terms of
the exact types and stages of cancer and
what sorts of pretreatment they have
received otherwise one could draw very
invalid conclusions from comparing
trials that are the same sorts of
patients one of the other applications
of this model of drug independence is
that it can be applied to forecast the
efficacy of combination therapies based
upon mono therapy data now as you'll see
in the top left here this is not a model
that predicts that all combination
the therapies are going to be beneficial
for example when looking at responses to
precisely what docetaxel in our
rearranged lung cancer we wouldn't
expect very much benefit of adding
docetaxel the croissant ultimately
because croissant live is so much
stronger therapy that that's typically
going to be the best thing for it for
everybody as competitors at AXA in other
cases for example in b-raf mutant
melanoma
one would expect that simply because the
b-raf inhibited - prathab and the immune
checkpoint inhibitor the volume at each
of those have a pretty substantial
chance of producing a durable response
to therapy in patients having those two
substantial chances of durable response
can be expected to give rise to a fairly
significant improvement in the odds of
survival even if there was not any form
of additive or synergistic interaction
among the two therapies and going
through all of the different track
response data in nevada so xena grants
only 5% of combinations were predicted
to surpass the best mono therapy for
that chamber type often the reason that
happen would be the even if drive a + B
we're going to be better together than
either one alone there might be some
other drug X which is a far superior
more active agent for that tumor type
and that gives rise to the phenomenon
where many sorts of combinations just do
not surpass the best single therapy for
that tumor nervous is an argument
against finding synergistic combinations
we can see in human clinical trials and
we can see in xenograph data some set of
combinations which really do give rise
to substantial synergistic effects and
that's illustrated in this example of
xenografts of melanoma here where
they're treated with a combination of
the CDK inhibitors cyclic and the neck
inhibited mini magnet that combination
showed a vastly superior response to the
prediction of independent action and
among the clinical trials that we looked
at many of them were beneficial and
approved combinations even without
synergistic effects so if these sorts of
large synergistic interactions could
translate into human Krauser
in the future we could see some really
beneficial responses to combination
therapies if we can find the right sets
of drugs and the right patient
populations where synergistic
interactions will truly occur there is
both some cause for caution here a need
to be very careful about how we measure
synergy in preclinical settings because
in most of the clinical trials that I
presented there were experiments in cell
lines or mouse models that did show
evidence of synergistic interactions
which somehow did not manifest in the
human clinical trial data one example of
this comes from experiments in
colorectal cancer cell lines treated
with sort of somatic and oxaliplatin in
cell lines they showed a very strong
degree of synergistic effect a
combination index of 0.1 meaning the
combination was 10 times more potent in
the dose response function than the
single agents and when that cell line
that showed a synergistic interaction
was implanted into a mouse xenograft
the combination of the therapy
illustrated in blue the blue growth
curve here on the right was far superior
to the activity of either of the single
agents shown in yellow and red now if we
compare the activity of this combination
therapy in human clinical trials in
chaos wild-type colorectal cancer we can
see on the bottom right hand side here a
curve in pink which shows the survival
benefit of treating patients with
Satoshi map mono therapy in the case of
patients whose cancer was refractory to
chemotherapy so after chemotherapy
failed they received so toxin n by
itself and this provided some
improvement to survival so focusing that
was then tested in much larger clinical
trials combining it with cocktails of
cytotoxic chemotherapy including Fleur
uracil combined with Aaron a chicken or
obsolete plantain and once observed
there was the benefits shown in blue as
compared to the survival curve in green
if we take that a shaded pink area which
is
the magnitude of survival improvement
conferred by statics a map and map that
on to the baseline survival function of
chemotherapy only in green that makes a
prediction the line shown there in black
the simulated combination of just adding
on the benefit of sux an AB mono therapy
and you can see that that modelled line
in black fully accounts for the clinical
benefit of the clinical benefits of the
combination shown in blue which shows
that yes it took some that did improve
patients duration of survival but it
improved it to the same degree where
that you give it by itself or if you
combine it with chemotherapy so it helps
but it's very clear in the human data
that there is no synergistic interaction
between the drugs even though in the
mouse model Vader and the cell line data
it appeared to be spectacularly superior
when they were combined as compared to
when they were used as single agents
there are a number of possible
explanations why it might be that the
synergy in the preclinical setting has a
hard time translating into the clinical
setting some of this might lie in the
pharmacokinetic variability or if
synergy is very susceptible to genetic
background or issues of experimental
design but I think the heterogeneity of
patient populations or the heterogeneity
of tumors may itself be one of the major
parts of the problem and that's
illustrated in the schematic here where
every circle represents a tumor and they
are shaded in blue or red in proportion
to their strength of response to each of
two drugs what you see in this scenario
is that the majority of the tumors are
responding either to neither therapy or
the responses largely dominated by one
or the other drug there may be some
fraction of patients who respond very
strongly to both drugs and this might be
that often part for survival curve where
it is difficult to quantify the benefit
of the combination therapy and the
facilities going to be observable in a
clinical setting it may be most evident
in this middle scenario this territory
where each of two therapies are giving
some powerful response and together they
add after more and this is the
sort of scenario that one tends to
investigate in a preclinical experiment
partial inhibitory doses of two trout's
as was illustrated in that previous
slide looking at office early planning
combined with satou-san that so I think
what this this view of heterogeneity and
the patient population suggests is that
even if mechanisms of interaction
between drugs that give rise to
synergistic killing of cancer cells even
if they occur in human populations and
clinical trials it might manifest in a
meaningful way and only a minority of
the patient population that might be
statistically difficult to detect in a
clinical trial now ultimately this is a
call for a creative precision in knowing
who needs one or the other single drugs
or which subsets of patients if any are
truly going to have a synergistic
benefit from a combination therapy this
is understanding of a patient to patient
variability and drug response also has
implications for how we evaluate
different single therapies and that's
nicely illustrated by this data from
pancreatic tumors in degraaf's treated
with a chemotherapy germ cytidine in
green or a MEK inhibitor Binnie magnet
in Perl what we see here is if you look
at the survival functions for these two
different modes of treatment there's no
difference between the two of them and
one might look at and think that there
isn't a role for the kinase inhibitor as
compared to the standard chemotherapy
agent because it's no better whoo when
we look at how the individual tumors
respond to each of the two therapies we
can see that there is some subset of the
tumors for whom any magnet is a superior
treatment option and some other subsets
that do not respond very well but that
time is inhibitor and for whom the
chemotherapy gems intervene is the
superior treatment option so a clinical
trial that might be deemed a failure
because there's no difference between
the activity of two drugs really all
it's telling you is that there's no
difference between the two on average
and what's best for patients on average
can be very different from what's best
for the individual and if we were able
to find biomarkers to identify the
subsets of patients who are more
responsive to one or the other then we
could find defined
and subsets for human youth therapy is
really a superior treatment option even
though it might not be better on average
so the conclusions then are the truck
combinations give each patient more
chances to receive at least one
personally effective drug this is not
the only cause of benefit of combination
therapy but it can be a substantial
cause of benefit when cross resistance
between drugs are low and when they have
a significant degree of activity in some
fraction of the patient population
so I've described a drug independence
model with an equation that's easy for
other people to apply for the analysis
of clinical trials data and this can
look at clinical trial data comparing
mono therapy stew combination therapies
to identify cases where combination
therapies really do have an additive or
synergistic effect this sort of analysis
could be applied in a by irma a
stratified fashion to find if in a
subset of patients it's consistent with
independent benefit if in some other
subset of patients we might see evidence
of synergistic activity and can also be
applied to the analysis of mono therapy
data to estimate the activity of novel
drug combinations under an assumption of
known drug drug interactions now in
practice sometimes there will be
antagonistic or synergistic effects
between drugs and combinations but this
provides an estimate of the likely
magnitude of activity which empirically
is awfully rather accurate and what this
means for the future of cancer therapy
is that combinations which are
beneficial for reasons other than having
an additive or synergistic interaction
if it's really just about a bet hedging
type of benefit at the population scale
those lots of combinations have the
potential to be replaced by a biomarker
stratified choice of treatment or
alternatively the sequential use of the
treatments whether this sort of approach
is desirable as compared to the
combination therapy would depend upon
the degree of toxicity of the
combination therapies and it would
degree and it would depend upon our
ability to actually identify some sort
of biomarker identifying who respond to
which particular therapy
so I mentioned things play out very
differently in leukemias and finalists
oh those are cancer types as well as a
few cases of solid tumors where viewers
can be obtained in a large fraction of
patients with combination therapy now
mono therapy treatments are almost never
curative of advanced cancers and so it's
very clearly the case in any combination
therapy that can achieve queues of
patients the combinations of drugs
simply must be adding up to something
more than the best single agent activity
in this fraction of the patients
illustrated in the purple box here for
example so it's not the topic of today's
seminar but if you're interested in
reading more about this phenomenon I've
included a link here to a preprint on
bio archive studying a 5 drug
combination therapy called our chopped
which has been used for about 20 years
now to cure a majority of patients with
diffuse large b-cell lymphoma and what
we observe in that particular study
performed by myself Christopher
Cheerilee and Peter Sagar is that the
combinations of multiple independently
active therapies they tend to add up in
a fairly predictable manner for example
if drug a kills 99% of the cancer cells
and drug B equals 99% of the cancer
cells the combination will kill 99.99%
of the cancer cells if they are subject
to different resistance mechanisms so
I'll indulge in a little bit of
speculation here to think about what
this means for the design of combination
therapies and what this means for the
role of precision medicine in oncology
so from the data that I presented the
picture that emerges is the different
drugs have different degrees of activity
across different patients you guys
illustrated here with these different
lengths of arrows and there are fencing
combinations if they are mechanistically
independent rows that kill cancer cells
in different ways then their effects in
combination tends to be fairly
predictable so what does this mean for
how to design combination therapies well
one of the approaches that has been
pursued historically was the method
developed by Donald Pinkle for the
treatment of childhood
lukemia where I started the seminar data
from that in 1961 when they sort of
moved beyond to drug combinations to
four or five or six or seven drug
combination therapies they pursued this
approach called total therapy which
really meant using all the drugs for all
the patients and if that is intolerable
for people yes you can achieve a far
stronger degree of cancer cell killing
but given this view that what we know is
that every single drug is active in some
patients and inactive in other patients
I think that what's occurring with
combination therapies like this is that
you could have drugs using the
combination where in many of the
patients they don't particularly need it
and there is some degree of bet hedging
going on with the use of lots and lots
of drugs increases the probability that
you will have many of them that are
active in each individual and it
suggests that it's not necessary to give
all of the drugs to all of the patients
if you know which ones would be most
active in which patient so I think what
this suggests is the approach of the
design the best combination therapies
would depend upon choosing the
ingredients of those combinations with
precision to treat each patient with the
drugs that are most highly active
killing their particular cancer and
minimize unnecessary toxicity now this
is a very tough scientific challenge and
it's a very tough practical clinical
challenge if this was delving into a
space of many novel combination
therapies some random selection of them
could have unpredictable toxicities when
delivered in combinations what I believe
might be a more practically achievable
goal in the near term could be described
as personalized consolidation of a
standard first-line therapy but perhaps
patients receive as a current matter of
course a combination of three drugs ABC
and rather than pursuing an approach
where we take one other new therapy and
combine that with a B and C for all of
the patients rather among the set of
therapies that we have we try to find
which will be most active for each
individual so apply the methods of
precision medicine to know for each
individual what other therapy is going
to be best for them and make that
part but the combination therapy that
they receive so you can to read the
final conclusion here I think the best
drug combinations are going to be made
by selecting the ingredients with
precision so ultimately the challenges
of combination therapy for cancer and
precision therapy for cancer I think are
in tallit challenges so I'd like to
thank my advisor Peter Sagar and my
co-author on the work in lymphoma
Christopher tiddly and a variety of
clinicians and scientists whose
discussions made this work possible
data on xenograph from Novartis which
was published and made available to
everybody and funding agencies thank you
very much and I hope to answer some of
your questions online thank you thank
you dr. Palmer for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible as a final reminder our
speaker will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
that is all for now thank you for
joining us we'll see you next time
goodbye